Why do some people think that the COVID shot can cause cancer?
Because it can. So the COVID-19 shot has been showed through numerous studies
to increase one risk, one's risk for cancer. I cannot tell you how many people that we've had
called our office that said they were just diagnosed with cancer. It was not long after they had
the COVID-19 vaccination or booster or that their cancer came back with the vengeance after
when it was in revision for a number of years after they got the vaccine. There's a lot of data
out there. I won't go into that anymore. If you really want to search that data, there's research
articles that have been buried, that do show that increased incidence of cancer and what are
called turbo cancers. They've been termed turbo cancers because they can they can be very, very
fast growing cancers that nobody can seem to put the brakes on. There's also evidence that the
COVID vaccine contained SV-40 as one of the components of the vaccine, which is known cancer-causing
particle that is used in laboratories to produce cancer in lab rats in order to test different
medications against it. So they'll give a lab rat SV-40 in order to produce cancer so that they can
test their chemotherapy against that cancer. Why would you put it in the COVID shot? Are there
nefarious reasons for all these things? Yeah, well, probably. So I've said way back when COVID came out
that you did not want to get that vaccine.